what's up baby
this week on thug notes we gettin loose
with The Scarlet Letter by the thank you
honk phone up in Salem Massachusetts
where everybody got real tight [ __ ]
homies gathered to peep the public
humiliation of some thick honey named
Hester Prynne see the one time found
Hester guilty of sleeping around like a
skank and getting knocked up now she got
a spot of red a on her threads to
signify adultery the people be all like
yo [ __ ] you better fess up the name of
your baby daddy but has to keeps his
Street and don't snitch while she being
all hated on by the hood she peeps her
old huh being a crowd who till now she
thought got ganked that see this fool
get all crunk is saying that the man she
whoring it up with got to get his to so
he'd go by the fake name adopt
Illingworth
and hit the streets to find a fool who
banged his woman after has to get
released from the slammer
she shacks up in some dingy as digs with
her baby girl pearl the local preacher
man Dimmesdale gets all sick and docked
he'll start nursing him when he starts
thinking maybe this fool ill cuz he got
some fussing to do so one night chilly
scoping out while he's sleeping a sees a
big red a on his chest naturally no
hoobin raw doggin hester then has to get
tired of chilly bustin her baby daddy's
balls and asked him to stop hatin but
chilly be all like can't stop won't stop
so has to tell Dimmesdale that
Chillingworth her old hubby later while
Dimmesdale sermonizing he sees Hester
and pearl in the crowd loses it starts
telling her body that he's pearls dead
then he swivels up and dies like a [ __ ]
since chilly ain't got nobody to [ __ ]
with no more he up and dies two years
later
Hester goes back to her cottage in the
boonies where she builds a rep for
giving advice to other women when she
dies she gets buried next to Dimmesdale
with a big ass a on their gravestone
even the scrappiest hoods you know that
Hester's a standing for adultery but
listen good blood cuz that ain't all it
means like one has to start doing
righteous deeds for the community homie
start thinking that ain't stands for
Abel and when people see a big a in the
sky after Winthrop's the farm they
thinking it means angel but no matter I
legit has to play that a isolating her
from all the other players in town who
fronted sandy are pure and uppity ever
since Adam took a bite out of that Apple
and got his ass booted out of Eden
sinners isolated man from society
himself and even God and system
appearances ain't down with Hester's bad
self she got to live in a cottage and
bump nowhere Chile sin Avengers get so
real that he loses himself entirely the
narrator even say that with his ventures
all cashed out he ain't got nothing to
do but go chill was singin and sure
there was no more Devils work on earth
for him to do it only remained for the
unhuman eyes mortal to betake himself
whether his master would find them task
enough and pay him his wages duly but
the truth up in is that all these
self-righteous posers ain't being real
and admitting that they just as humans
fester
cuz no matter how hard you try to stick
to the straight and narrow acting out is
a part of human nature
anybody that say they never trip in the
face of temptation is the real line
trick so what hard phone might be saying
is if everybody is assembled till we
stop hating so much whenever somebody
sup cuz if you gonna say life is based
on love and compassion you gotta know
how to forgive player
stay in school say no to drugs and tell
all your friends about thug notes catch
your ass next week
days